hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
t helper cells now t helper cells are
important component of our immune system
if we think our immune system to be a
defense system of a country then these t
helper cells would be considered as the
land troopers
or army ranger so let us talk about
what are the important functions of t
helper cell how they are developed
and what is the consequence how they are
matured and how they are
important for the immune system and this
video is pretty much detailed
so look at the timestamps in the
description for a better understanding
but please stay tuned till the end of
this video
t cells are born in the bone marrow from
the lymphoid progenitor
the lymphoid progenitor give rise to t
cell precursor
and the b cell precursor eventually the
t cell precursor would be secreted into
bloodstream
and they would eventually migrate
towards the thymus
where the further steps of t cell
development would occur but before
going to that let me tell you that t
cells take very important steps towards
immunity
they interact with antigen presenting
cells such as dendritic cells
and that ensures t cells should be
activated
upon any kind of infections and the
activated t cells
further do important job for example
activated t cells
can activate b cells now when b cell is
activated
it forms or it differentiates into
plasma cells
plasma cells are secretion factory for
antibodies thus humoral immune response
is indirectly uh indirectly augmented by
t cell activity or t helper cell
activity
now there are several sub types of t
helper cells
these sub type of t helper cells have
their individual functions
some of them are very helpful to combat
viruses
one t cell subtype known as th1 subtype
they help to combat viruses in other
words
these subtype of t cells are crucial for
immune responses
another sub type t regulatory cell
is very important and work like a break
on immune responses it prevents the
activity of macrophages
or several innate and adaptive immune
components and thereby ensures that our
body does not have a harmful effect of
hyperactivation of the immune system and
it decrease
the probability of autoimmune diseases
now let us understand the overall
developmental scheme of t cells
because t helper cells are developed in
different
places and they are residing later on in
different
places so it is pretty confusing if we
don't have a road map to it
so the development starts at bone marrow
where we have t cell precursor
which is eventually formed which is
actually formed from the
lymphoid progenitor cells now in the
bone from the bone marrow they migrate
towards the thymus
in the thymus the t helper cell subtype
specification take place
and then they move out to lymph node so
lymph node
is their posting ground now in lymph
node
they interact with antigen presenting
cells and thereby gets activated
they can also get differentiated into
several subtypes such as th1 th2 th17
cells
so in short the birthplace of the t
cells are bone marrow
whereas the training school where their
lineage commitment happens or whether
their
antigen determining training is
happening is actually the
thymus and their differentiation is
taking place in the lymph node
so all of this is very important to
understand the function and the
developmental scheme of t helper cells
so let us
try to understand this process in
details
so the part of t cell development takes
place in
thymus so they are born in the bone
marrow but eventually they move into the
thymus as if thymus is a
training school for the t cells so if we
take a cross section of the thymus and
try to understand the detailed structure
then we can understand the t cell
development inside the thymus
so look at this structure right now in
the cross section of a thymus
this looks like this picture and we have
several anatomical zones such as
subcapsular region
cortex cortico corticomedulary junction
and eventually the medulla
now that naive t cell the immature t
cells
come inside the thymus from high
endothelial venule
and from there they eventually migrate
towards the subcapsular region to the
towards the periphery
where they increase in number and they
proliferate
at this stage they have a different name
but from after they proliferate they
eventually move towards the cortex
from cortex they move towards medulla
cortico medullary junction
and once they reach the medulla by that
time they are already
their subtypes are specified so let us
understand this
chronology in bit more details so in the
subcapsular region the t cells that are
present there
are known as double negative this is
a lifetime life phase of the t cell so
these are not different type of t cells
this is kind of a life stage okay now
these double negative t cells they don't
have cd4
they don't have cd8 core receptors
neither of them
now they have the t cell receptor alpha
beta t cell receptor or
gamma delta t cell receptor actually the
stage is
further divided into few many steps like
dn1 dn2 these are transition states so
we don't focus on that
too much but next step they move towards
cortex
and now they would be known as the
double positive stage
because they have also cd
4 core receptor and the cd 8 co receptor
both the receptors are present
and 80 of the cells are actually double
positive
now this double positive interacts with
the thymocytes
where they get very important training
which is
important for their maturation now in
the thymocytes
they learn how to recognize
antigens which are bound to mhc
molecules and two distinct selection
process occurs
in their lifespan one is positive
selection they have to learn how to
recognize mhc if they fail to recognize
they would be eliminated
and negative selection so you have to
learn to recognize otherwise you would
be eliminated
now this positive selection and negative
selection
ensures that only few of these t cells
can move towards the next round of
selection so
there is a stringency now in the
positive selection
only the t cells that are passed in this
positive selection
who learn how to recognize mhc molecules
they would be
kind of um
promoted towards next level or otherwise
they would be neglected and they would
be
dead so this is called death by neglect
mostly 90 percent of the cells
are dying due to this kind of process so
very
less amount of cells are actually
maturing
then in the next round of selection
process
if you have a low affinity interaction
then you can go to the next round but if
your interaction is
too high then the body would think it's
a danger these kind of t cells might
lead to autoimmune responses so that is
why these cells would be
death dead by apoptosis
now these double positive cells
when moved to cortico-medullary junction
they learn how to recognize
antigens from class 1 mhc or class
2 mhc now if they recognize the antigens
from class 2 mhc
they would down regulate cd8 expression
whereas upregulate cd4 expression they
would eventually become
a t hell person so we understand how t
helper cells
are specified now
if they recognize
class 1 mhc bound antigens then they
would eventually become
a t cytotoxic cell they would down
regulate cd4 whereas upregulate cd8
point to be noted if they don't regulate
anything
they would be dead but if they regulate
both of
class 1 mhc and class 2 mhc bound
peptides
then also they would be dead and it
would be considered as a
danger signal so they would be dead now
naive t
cells which are cd4 type c t cells
they have to recognize antigens from mhc
2 type of peptides now mhc 2 bound
peptides
are actually presented to the naive
helper t cells
now notice the term naive written in red
naive means they have the certificate
to recognize antigens but they have not
done it
in their real life so they have not
encountered any
pathogen per se so these are known as
naive t cells but they would eventually
meet the pathogen when they are posted
to the
lymph nodes now now if t cells
can be differentiated into knife cd8
positive
cd four positive t cells or t helper
cells can be differentiated into sub
populations
such as th1 cell th17 cells t regulatory
cells or th2 cells
and each of these differentiation
process is dependent upon specific
polarizing
cytokine coming from various sources now
all of these sub population have their
distinct function for example
th1 cell is mainly involved against
viral
responses or against intracellular
pathogens it is also involved in
inflammatory processes
th7 helps to combat fungal infections
and bacterial infections
whereas t regulatory cell work like a
break in the immune response and it
prevents
hyperactivation of the immune system
th2 cells protects against extracellular
pathogens
and particularly it is involved in
allergic responses
so we understand that even under t
helper cell
there are so many subtypes depending
upon what type of cytokines they are
encountering
they are further specified into sub
population and subtypes
each having distinct function now let me
tell you that t
cells are very much important for body's
immune system and in disease like hiv
aids
your cd4 positive helper t cells are
dead
so the hiv virus interacts with the cd4
positive helper t cells and they infect
these cd4
helper t cells and while proliferating
inside these
t helper cells eventually they kill the
t helper cells and the number of t
helper cells reduce dramatically in the
body
as a result severe immunodeficiency
occurs
and the risk of secondary infection
increases several fold
also the understanding that t helper
cell is very
important for body's immune system came
from the analysis
of nude mouse nude mouse was a
laboratory strain of mice
which have which don't have the thymus
so when thymus was
absent then the t helper cell cannot be
produced
as a result what happens this mouse
becomes
severely immunocompromised so in this
video if you try to summarize we have
looked at the detailed developmental
scheme of t helper cell
functions of the t helper cell and how t
h or t helper cell differentiate into
specific sub population
so i hope you enjoyed this video if you
like this video give it a quick thumbs
up don't forget to like share and
subscribe thank you